no es la primera vez que un gran artista
se ve implicado en una polémica de este
tipo que es necesario entonces para que
una canción sea considerada considerada
plagio y Qué herramientas tiene un
tribunal para acreditarlo
Rodrigo Muchísimas gracias por la
invitación básicamente un plagio se da
cuando una persona trata de atribuirse
una obra que no es suya como diciendo
esta que es de alguien más yo la pongo a
mi nombre casi siempre mediante una
copia en un tribunal lo que analiza son
básicamente unos cinco elementos más o
menos que explicando lo rápido podrían
ser si la melodía que es la parte que
nos sirva por ejemplo se parece si la
letra se parece si la armonía que son
las las notas los acordes que están por
debajo se parecen si los elementos
rítmicos de la letra y eso digamos es
cómo se están diciendo las palabras En
qué en qué manera cómo estamos haciendo
el énfasis como eso eso cómo cacha con
la melodía Cómo se están diciendo y
también otra cosa que podríamos Llamar
el contexto rítmico que es además como
los elementos del género musical del que
estamos hablando en esta demanda
específicamente se tomaban uno solo de
esos que era la armonía y decían que ese
armonía y ese feeling se estaba copiando
y realmente no y pues afortunadamente
se falló a favor de chiva en que había
compuesto pues una canción completamente
original Bueno agradeció al Jurado por
una decisión que según dijo ayudará a
proteger el proceso creativo de
cantautores en Estados Unidos y en el
mundo hasta qué punto tienen hoy en día
las manos atadas por los derechos de
autor los artistas a la hora de componer
no yo creo que no las tienen atadas de
ninguna manera las tienen atadas Qué
sucede Y es que hay una cosa que es
demandar y otra cosa es ganarse las
demandas y son cosas diferentes
han caído varios que simplemente quieren
demandar y No necesariamente tienen los
argumentos para ganarse las demandas lo
que pasa con el que ellos ya habían
ganado una demanda del 2015
Williams por pues la canción de
y digamos que tenían como ganas de
seguir explorando estos estos asuntos
qué pasa y es yo no creo que tenga las
manos atadas los cantautores y los
compositores y demás Pueden seguir
tranquilos que siempre y cuando ellos o
ellas estén haciendo las canciones ellos
mismos pues las cosas van a salir bien
que si están tomando de nosotros Claro
ahí hay que preocuparse pero pero
siempre que estén componiendo de su
propia inspiración y su propio trabajo
lo más probable es que lo estén haciendo
bien ustedes abogado en este tipo de
temas quería preguntarle si normalmente
prosperan este tipo de denuncias
en algunos casos sí en algunos casos No
creo yo lo llamo el factor gastritis Así
es como creo que hay más denuncias que
las cosas que se ganan
sin embargo en ciertos géneros se ganan
estas denuncias solo por un fenómeno que
es otro que es cuando hablamos de
remixes cuando hablamos de utilizar
samples de otras canciones o
interpolaciones en los géneros urbanos
en el reggaetón en estas cosas allí esos
reclamos sí prosperan solo porque no se
habían pedido los permisos suficientes
pero es otra discusión diferente no es
de plagio no es de apropiárselo de
alguien más es haber utilizado otra cosa
sin autorización es una sutileza pero es
un poco diferente